welcome to the final episode of tricky
elephant gambit
where we are going to look at the
sidelines
now you should pay special attention to
them as
at lower level this occurs very
frequently
[Music]
the first move i want to consider is
bishop to b5 check
and in my blitz games i face it very
oftenly
but
just one more
c6
and if white continue with some of the
most popular choices
then the opening disaster is looming in
the air
for example if he plays bishop to e4
then we can take on e4
and the point after knight x e5 and the
move queen to d4
black wins the piece at just
fifth move of the game
so good to believe it right but that
happens
well the same story goes if the bishop
goes to the d3 square
trying to protect e4 pawn
but this time around after d takes e4
bishop takes e4 and the move f5
it doesn't matter however white wriggles
he cannot save the piece
for example if bishop to d3 then e4 naps
the bs so that is right out of the
equation
and white can try over here a tricky
move
knight captures e5
hoping that black foolishly take on e4
so that queen to h5 check
comes with a deadly effect
but black is not a fool
and just one simple move
queen to d6
whereupon two of the white pieces
hanging
and this queen to h5 check is now
absolutely garbage
as
g6
knight takes g6
we can exchange the queen
and when white bishops move somewhere
if you count the material
black obtain a piece for a two pawn
which is a huge opening advantage
so in a nutshell this royal lopez bishop
to b5 check
doesn't working against
our tricky elephant gambit
the second move i want to consider is d3
choose by a player who doesn't know the
theory and get out of our sharp lines
well guess what
i have two options for you
if
you are an endgame expert
then you can simply take on e4 and after
d takes e4 and queen exchange
white get misplaced king
and black is already slightly better
so that is one good option
instead of d captures e4 here white can
also try knight captures e5
but as you are going to see that after
knight to f6
white light square bishop remain the
passive piece
and on top of everything if white plays
the move d4 here
then we get the upgrade version of d4
mainline
starting with knight to d7
and soon you will see the difference
that in this variation
black get a free tempo with knight to f6
as white has wasted one move with d3 and
then d4
now rather than going for the end game
if you are like me who likes the
tactical battle
then i have the second option for you
and that is
knight to c6
whereupon we insist that white bishop
remain the passive here
and if we continue with moves such as
bishop to e2 and knight c3
then
d4 is always on the car with some space
in the center of the bowl
so that is the reason why as per the
database
white has gone for this variation
e captures d5
queen captures d5
knight to c3 attacking the queen
we pin down this knight and after bishop
to d2
we don't waste any time
bishop takes c3 bishop takes c3
and now very important maneuver you have
to remember that is
97 knight to g6 and then knight to f4
combining with bishop to g4
gives black a great advantages position
let me show you how
considering the most popular choice by
white that is he liked to go on the
kingside castle with bishop to e2
and after knight to g6 and the castle
we achieve what we want to do
knight to f4
hitting the bishop and
bishop to g4 is indeed on the agenda
in fact there is a high profile grand
master game exist in the database
where white tried rook to e1
and after bishop to g4
what else but bishop to f1
unleashing
the three attackers
on the e5 square
so at first sight this looks scary
but see the preparation from the black
as he continue with the accurate
response
castle on the queen side
where funny enough some of the obvious
response such as h3 and bishop takes e5
leads to disaster
for example if your opponent continue
with h3
then the simple is you take on h3 and
after pawn takes and bishop takes
not only black come out with a clear
pawn advantage
but white king is wide open and invite
all sorts of attack
so this is right out of the equation
what about the second choice namely
bishop takes e5 at this position
well this is again those illusionary
moves
which creates the big problem
s after knight takes e5
rook takes e5
black has a very simple response namely
queen captures e5
where the end results
knight takes e5 bishop takes d1
if white takes the bishop then we are
clear exchange up
so the more critical response is knight
captures f7 attacking both of the rooks
but then black can simply save the
bishop and after knight captures d8 and
the move rook captures d8
if you count the material
no surprise
black emerged with a clear piece
advantage
so considering all these factors in the
game white played the move rook to e3
defending the knight
but then black attack commenced with
some obvious moves
knight to d4
pressurizing the f3 knight
so why chop it off
but after pawn takes d4 white rook get
attack
and in the game white choose rook to e4
counter attacking the black knight
whereupon black played a simple move
g5
where f5 is coming up
so why desperately played queen to e1
which at the end turned out as a big
mistake
because after bishop takes f3 pawn takes
f3 and the move f5
white moves the rook only to find the
root shock
queen captures f3
where not only he has opened up the
white king with a clear pawn advantage
but he has a tactical resource that
if white foolishly continue with
rook captures f5 then queen to g4
naps the rook and in fact the game
finally let's move on to the main move
d4
and against this my recommendation is
very simple
you take on e4 and after knight takes e5
pay attention guys as white is
threatening bishop to c4
so do not play casual moves such as
knight to f6
and i don't like bishop to d6 as knight
to c4 attack of a bishop
so accordingly the accurate response is
knight to d7
immediately challenging this centralized
white knight
now as i highlighted over here white has
few options
and amongst them knight captures d7 is
the main line
however
first let's look at other moves and find
out
what we are going to do about them
number one bishop to c4 is a bad move in
this position
the simple reason is after knight takes
e5
pawn takes e5 and now once we extend the
queen and play bishop to c5
yes the material is balanced
but black has some simple plan as i have
shown by the arrows
and most important factor is
white has a misplaced keying
so considering all this factor
it is black who get slightly better
outcome from this transaction
the second move i want to consider is
knight to c4
and against this
i am proposing you should challenge this
knight immediately with
knight to b6
and our overall goal is we provoke white
to take this knight so that it help us
to open the a5
let's see how we can achieve this
so now if white goes back on e5 then
bishop to d6 is a strong reply
so the majority of the games continue
with knight to c3 attacking on e4
whereupon we immediately pin down this
knight
with bishop to b4
white can't play bishop to d2 as the d
pawn hang
so majority of the games continue with
bishop to e2
and now comes the point where we can
force this transaction by playing
bishop to e6
if knight to e3 then we can play f5 f4
and that makes this bishop unhappy
so majority of the games continue with
knight captures b6
something which we are definitely
looking into this line
where after a text b6
black has a simple plan
f5 knight f6 castle
and the added benefit you should always
remember the open a file
gives black some important tactical idea
in the upcoming middle game
the third move i want to consider is
bishop to f4
whereupon
i propose this very tricky setup
starting with
knight to f6
and when white plays the most popular
choice bishop to c4 attacking on f7
this is the exact moment
where we take on e5
if pawn takes then black exchanged the
queen with a better position
so white has to take back with the
bishop
and then simple move bishop to d6
challenging it immediately
okay if white take over bishop then we
capture back with the queen
with a superior development so that is
the reason why majority of the games
continue with castle on the king side
whereupon we can deliver this surprising
package
knight to g4
and black has some cruel idea including
queen to h4 and create pressure on this
weak white king
well recently i reached to this position
against a 2200
where my opponent played a very
important move bishop to g3
stopping our execution
not to worry
i castle on the king side well s3 messed
up the white pawn structure
so wisely enough he decided to play rook
to even
attacking on my e4
but i found an excellent counter reply
namely
queen to f6
whereupon my threat is very simple
first i want to get rid of this bishop
and then take on f2
something which white need to address
immediately
in the game he tried queen to e2
but what he has missed is
bishop takes g3 h captures g3 and now
this deciding queen slider
where after just 12 move white get a
hopeless position
the game finished very quickly my
opponent plays queen to d1
i give him some checks
and when king comes on e2
i simply take on g2
okay f2 is hanging so he played rook to
f1
but
exactly here
the deciding blow happens and that is e3
stripping off the white king
and in fact after few moves indeed black
managed to win the game
the fourth move i want to consider is
f4
and against this
once again we are going to follow a
grand master game which gives us a clear
path
how to handle this radiation
and i think he choose the top choice
namely
knight to h6
whereupon the idea is very nice
when white plays
his top database choice namely
bishop to c4
we can respond first with knight to b6
attacking the bishop
and when bishop goes to b3
this lethal queen check
gives black a comfortable advantage
the point is after g3 and queen h3 we
stop white to castle on the king side
so in the majority of the cases white
has dried the move queen to e2
attacking on e4
whereupon black simply respond with f6
attacking the knight
and after knight to c4
black can sets up a small trap here
starting with knight capture c4
so that if white thought that he can
play this in between move
queen captures e4
then after queen to e4
why to his horror find out that
he is going to lose the whole piece
for absolutely nothing
so watch out for this as this is more
common
well
white choose the accurate path he
captured on c4
and from here onwards black planning of
campaign remain very simple
first bishop to f5
and after knight to c3
he simply castle on the coin side
of course you can't take on e4 because
of rook captures d4
so i thought okay first i am going to
defend my d pawn with bishop to e3
and ready to castle
but black simply doesn't allow this
he responded with bishop to b4
and the threat is very simple if you
castle then bishop to g4 naps the
exchange
so in the game white fed up with his
passive position
and lash out with a3
where
after few moves
bishop takes c3
pawn takes c3 bishop to g4
queen to f1
trying desperately for the queen trade
but
black is more than happy as the pressure
is on the white so queen to h5
and since white was desperate for castle
he played bishop to e2
looks like the obvious choice
but after black's next reply more or
less the game is over
can you spot it
well congratulations if you see the move
queen to a5
which has a very simple threat namely
queen capture c3
and funny enough
white has no adequate defense
for example bishop to d2 runs into e3
and apart from it how the hell on earth
white is going to defend on c3 pawn
and i must give credit to white as he
choose the bold move namely king to d2
trying to defend his position
but now since white king caught in the
center
black shows the elegance
bishop takes e2
queen takes e2 and now wonderful reply
knight to f5
finish up the jaw
as we have a simple threat of knight
captures d4
something which white cannot prevent it
why try to safe on his king with e1
but queen capture c3 king to f2
and now nice finishing touch knight
captures e3
where white simply resigned the game in
the view of
queen takes e3
queen capture c2 and the end result
black has two pawn advantage and on top
of everything
white king looks
absolutely shaky
so this model game illustrate
after knight to at 6
how comfortable black position can
become in this line